I'm curious you brought up Majid and
Majid is has been on the show and we've
become friendly do you think his job
here is the hardest do you think it's
much harder than what I'm doing or what
you are doing or what Tommy's doing
because he's trying to reform the
religion from the inside and I see the
most hate and the worst things that that
people on the Left white people on the
left in America say about
maajid a brown Muslim man from Egypt so
he's getting it the worst from everybody
I think is his job the toughest yeah I
mean I don't envy invite by any means I
mean I get a lot of hate mail and all of
that but that it's nothing compared to
to what he goes through and if you look
at some of the things that people say to
him you know you and I would never get
away with things from something similar
to a brown met I mean we would rightly
called a racist and in the bigot and
then in a summer fo so I write hugely in
my what he's trying to do and obviously
there are two types of people that I
admire enormously you have on the 180 of
people like I and here's the alley
who's left her faith and it's now
campaigning really for people to have
the right to leave Islam and to
criticize the religion and then you have
people like Maajid who's that you
obviously had a change of heart but it's
still a Muslim and who wanted to reform
his faith from inside and you know these
are probably one of the most important
people at the moment that we should
support and align ourselves with because
let's be under no illusion whatsoever we
cannot win this fight without the
support and the friendship with people
from inside the community we need Muslim
leaders we need Muslims themselves
within within their communities to speak
up for a for a form of Islam that is
compatible with the modern world and we
see basically we see we see similar
things happening in Jordan and Egypt
where president Sisi and King Abdullah
are now finally you know
finding the words to address some of
these problems and that is hugely
important whatever else you may be think
about what president Sisi is doing to
journalists and to human rights activist
and I certainly don't approve of that
but I think he plays an important role
in fighting Islamic extremism yes so
that again that goes to the precarious
position that people that really care
for human rights are put in so Sisi is
doing terrible things for human rights
and minorities and he's basically he's
basically a military leader that took
power by a coup after they had the you
know the the actual democratic elections
that sort of ended up going the wrong
way but we have to play ball with him
because at least Egypt is a stable
country so if you care about human
rights it's like you have to play ball
with these strongmen and then at the
same time the strongmen do terrible
things it almost sounds like a repeat of
Saddam Hussein not to say he's doing the
types of violence to his own people that
Saddam was doing but is that just the
best we're ever gonna get out of this
part of the world well you know it's
always a mixture of optimism and realism
there in the Middle East there are no
pretty solutions to anything I mean even
if you look at the Kurds who I greatly
support there are still problems within
Kurdish societies that need to be
addressed so you do not find a perfect
regime or country in the Middle East not
even Israel I mean I'm a huge supporter
of Israel I'm a self-declared proud
finest I love I love the State of Israel
I think it's a beautiful country and a
democratic country but Israel is not
perfect and I disagreed with this well
on certain things now obviously Egypt is
a much more extreme example but I think
people have the intellectual capacity to
make a difference and say I completely
disagree with this human rights record
but I do acknowledge that he is trying
to you know trigger a debate about Islam
in the Muslim world that we really
really need and what the only option
that we then really have is to say like
we cooperate with him on that but we
don't stop criticizing him when he
arrests journalists or human rights
activist
or anyone else yeah what do you make of
the West's fascination or the left's
fascination I should say not the way
it's well it's everyone's fascination
everyone's fascination with Israel I
mean this is a piece of land that's the
size of New Jersey it has one
international airport you can drive east
and west of it the aboard erta border in
a couple hours I think like four hours
north and south in like six or eight
hours I mean it's an absurdly tiny piece
of land that gets all the media play
that people are obsessed with you know I
feel similarly to how you just described
it and of course it's not perfect and
they're in a very precarious place it's
hard when you have tiny little border
and the Middle East is a mess and
sometimes people die but what do you
make it just the fascination and the
endless the United Nations endless
assault on the one tiny little democracy
there yeah it's absolutely bizarre and I
know I'm going to get a hundred hate
mails just calling Israel a democracy
and not an apartheid state that engages
in the genocide of the Palestinian
people which by the way would be the
only genocide ever to take place in
history where the victim populations
increases right right so just to be very
can you just really lay that out I mean
the population of Gaza since 1967 is
sometimes something like four times
bigger or even eight times bigger I
think than it was back then so this is
not it's the reverse of the genocide not
to say everything's perfect but it is
certain side down yeah it's the only
genocide in history where the victim
population has included in the alleged
victim population has increased that
goes for both gar ZAR and enter the West
Bank and if you look at the standard of
living and something like health care
and life expectancy this has all
improved over the years now I'm not
saying that the Palestinians are not
suffering and that you know Israel is
always right in the way that it deals
with a problem not at all but to say
that Israel is engaging in a genocide I
mean the word genocide is a very very
serious allegation it is the crime of
all crimes that is just absolutely
bizarre and frankly it
relative Rises the concept of genocide
and it relativize us the crimes of
people that have actually committed a
genocide and the most bizarre thing
about it all is that the people who
accuse Israel of engaging in genocide as
often are very often aligned with Hamas
we're just actually preaching a genocide
or genocide against the Jewish people
that is the irony the absurdity about it
all right so that's what I've tried to
explain to people many times because
people say that somehow on this issue
I'm this right-wing maniac I'm for to
States but you have to have two actors
that are willing to have two states if
Hamas is only willing to have one state
you know look Israel left Gaza there's
not one Jew in Gaza right Hitler would
love the place there's actually a store
called Hitler it's a clothing store in
Gaza so it's like what do you want them
to do that's why it seems that's one of
the ones where religion is so tied to it
because in my opinion they just simply
they just don't want Jews there you're
absolutely right I mean if you not just
listening to what Hamas is saying but
also to what President Abbas is saying I
mean if Bibi Netanyahu is saying the
same things about Arabs and Palestinians
that the Palestinian Authority is saying
about Jews not just Israeli students in
general mm-hmm
I mean the entire world would probably
go up in flames it's it's completely
ridiculous and what is also completely
ridiculous sisters
be thou interdependent theory that
people somehow believe that if only we
were to solve this problem in this tiny
strip of land and all the ills of the
Arab Muslim world would disappear into
thin air I mean how is what we are
seeing in Syria related to the problem
in Palestine right there is no relation
there is no relation and it's unhealthy
obsession with Israel is is just I can't
wrap my head around it because again I'm
not saying that it's really a faith and
I consider myself a critical friend of
Israel that reserves the right to
criticize this railways rail is wrong
sure but if I look around in the
and I see what what's happening in Syria
and what the Saudis utter aid to women
in their own country while we why are we
having apartheid weeks at our
universities for Israel and never for
Saudi Arabia why are we having mass
demonstrations on European streets for
the Palestinians in Gaza in the West
Bank who are suffering of course but
that's nothing compared to what Bashar
al-assad is doing to them in Syria
starving them to death actually really
engaging in mass slaughter of
Palestinian know you don't hear these
people talking about it because it's not
really about Israel right I mean these
you know it's not really it's not really
about the Palestinians really these
people are not really Pro Palestinians
what they are really is hunting Israel
right so that's the fascinating part I
mean there was the Yarmouk refugee camp
in Syria which means there should be no
refugee camps in any of these Arab
countries for Palestinians but they've
kept Palestinians in refugee camps they
don't even let them become citizens
Assad killed about 2,000 of them within
the last two years nobody nobody seems
to care so as part of that that people
just don't care about history so for
example they'll say well go back to 1967
but it's not as if there was peace
before 1967 and also I'm pretty sure
that the West Bank was part of Jordan
and that Gaza was part of Egypt so it's
not as if the Palestinians had a state
then so it's like people just don't the
people love narrative over fact and I'm
seeing this bleed into almost everything
these days yes and it's also I mean they
call it sinus and sign of them today
what they aren't taking but what they
really very often mean is is Jews you
know sign is just become a clean word
the word to describe Jews yeah so it
actually still has a lot to do with
anti-semitism which never really went
away you know it took different forms
and different ways of describing it but
it really comes down in many cases to
the fact that people just don't want to
use their yeah now you realize people
are gonna say you're a paid Mossad agent
and I'm opposed to a Mossad agent and
we're working together on this
you know I'm really angry now that you
do my cover
and I was trying so hard you thought you
were being slick but they don't pay me
enough to really keep it a secret that's
the thing I get a call after the show
you know and I have to explain my father
all right well okay we only have a few
minutes left I want to circle back a
little bit to the European problem I saw
that this week in Denmark
that they're looking into stripping
citizenship of Imams who are preaching
hate and preaching things against the
state in Denmark now I my whole ethos is
about free speech everything that I do
here is about free speech so I'm very
torn on this one because I would
basically say that people can say
anything that they want as long as
they're not inciting to violence now it
seems to me that these Imams are
probably going as close to the line on
that as possible if they're preaching to
take down the state there's the at least
inclination or hint that it may be
through violent means where do you fall
now because I know you're huge on free
speech and secular values also I am but
I'm of course also of the belief that
above all we have to save God the lives
of innocent people living in our country
and we just had a case in the UK this
week that the Imam of the largest mosque
in in Scotland praised the assassination
of the anti-blasphemy activists in
Pakistan a couple of years ago and then
just hours later a shopkeeper who posted
a a message on Facebook congratulating
Christians for Easter was brutally
brutally murdered by Muslim by a Muslim
because he belongs to to to the
Ahmadiyya Muslims which is a a largely
peaceful and progressive movement within
the Islamic community and within the
Muslim world these people are often
called heretics and apostates and you
don't have to be surprised that if the
Imam of the largest mosque in Scotland
believes the disperse
illegitimate to murder people for
blasphemy what he actually meets is free
speech but what these people call
blasphemy right that we then see people
actually being murdered on our streets
in the name of their religion and I know
people would say now again no he was not
a Muslim and he was not there's nothing
to do with Islam
well it has something to do with Islam
because what these Imam is preaching is
based on Islamic teaching and there is
no way around it I mean we can deny the
problem and many people still prefer to
do that but it is a part of Islam and we
need to talk about it right so now I
know you've made this distinction
several times even in the course of this
interview but that there's a political
component to this so it's not just that
the Islamists have to blow up things and
then maybe force our governments to take
away our own freedoms to protect us but
that there's a political ideology that
they'll use the rights that the West
grants them to preach these things to
turn their own populace against us when
you start going down that route it all
starts sounding like a big conspiracy or
something that there really is this
massive invasion and I don't want to
start using the the fear-mongering
techniques that the right uses but that
that's real right that there's a
political element that goes beyond
violence here of course and I think it
was Gaddafi who said years ago that well
Muslims don't need terrorism to you know
infiltrate Western countries they just
do this by by immigrating to these
countries and then getting a lot of
children and because that brings me back
to to what I said before we are not just
fighting the jihadis those who commit
violence we also have to deal with the
Islamists who want to impose their way
of life on our societies but also with
the conservative Muslims or maybe not
Islamist and maybe not jihadis but who
had leads to a certain degree with some
of the things that these people are
saying because if you look at opinion
polls and I know this brings me
dangerously close to what happened to to
Sam Harris on that show you know with
Ben Affleck but if you're looking at
opinion polls I mean legitimate opinion
polls not some fringe crazy conspiracy
fear mongering opinion polls if you look
at what people in the Muslim world think
about apostates converting from the
religion leaving the religion it's
shocking it is shocking the percentage
of people who believe it is legitimate
to use violence against people just for
leaving the religion or converting to
another religion is to me absolutely
shocking yeah do you think the West is
fundamentally doing something wrong here
that somehow and I can even feel it when
I'm talking to you knowing that we go
out of our way to make this distinction
over and over that we still feel we have
to guard our words somehow and all this
and again as we've talked about that
sort of gives the strength to the to the
right but that the West is doing
something wrong in that we're not
selling why freedom is good anymore
there was a time where it was like it
was cool to really stand up for Western
value stand up for free speech and
religious plurality and rights of
minorities and all of those things and
for all the faults of the West and for
four wars that we probably shouldn't
have got into although there were as I
said at the top of the show there were a
thousand year-old blood feuds going on
in the Middle East far but before
America was a country but that nobody
really stands up there aren't public
figures anymore that stand up and say
you know what what we're doing here in
the UK is still good we still have more
integration here than they do in most
other places certainly in the United
States where people still want to come
you think we're just we're just not
doing a good cell job anymore I think
you you've raised two interesting points
here one is that yes indeed every time I
give such an interview I think about
what am I going to say because I know
there will be people out there watching
or just waiting for me to slip not even
intentionally just to slip and say
something they can then twist and turn
and make me sound like a racist and a
bigot and you know that there are people
like Reza Aslan and Glenn Greenwald who
do this on purpose and who have their
own malicious agenda and they know quite
well they are mister
presenting what we are saying but they
are saying it anyway because they are
too afraid to debate us with ideas so
all they can resort to is you know
smearing us and trying to silence our
that is one point and the second point
that you raised about not selling
ourselves anymore absolutely and you
guys in America are doing a bit more of
a better job at this than we do in
Europe because you're still proud well
yeah I mean if you look at it from a
European perspective now I left in
Washington DC for Harvey yeah and I will
really surprised how proud the Americans
really are about America I mean if you
come from from Europe it's still you
still feel like there is this proud
about America at least compared to to
Europe and we have to depart from this
perpetual sense of guilt you know and
and culture of self-destruction and self
blaming that we have somewhat to blame
for all the ills of the Middle East so
I'm not saying that colonial or
imperialist period was pretty you know
we didn't do terrible things to people
but this is not the reason why people
blow themselves up in Nigeria Indonesia
this comes down to the Islamist ideology
and these people can unite it as much as
they like and they pretend it all comes
down to us and again it's what George W
Bush called you know soft bigotry of low
expectations because somewhat you know
these brown people cannot be responsible
for their own fate it must always come
down to us it must always have something
to do with us they can say that as long
as they like it doesn't change the fact
it's not true and that you can explain
the global and I believe Maajid Nawaz
called that the global Islamist
insurgency you can only explain that and
it's roots with the ideology of Islamism
and not with Western foreign policy yeah
you know it's so funny so many of my
guests have mentioned the the phrase the
soft bigotry of low expectations and
many times on the show I kept quoting I
thought it was Bill Maher that had
coined the phrase so I felt good about
it then I learned it was George W Bush
it was one of his speech writers I've
been saying it less but maybe that's the
phrase that George W Bush gay
that that we don't have to be upset
about no and I mean it's quite funny you
know I talked about Iraq before and you
know there were actually people who
would have been happier to topple george
w bush and top of saddam hussein and
that really brings us back to the
absurdity after left and and everything
that we talked about today with for all
his paws and i know means george w bush
was not perfect but he was also not a
saddam hussein yeah
all right so final thought to wrap all
this up if you had a crystal ball and
you were looking five or ten years into
the future of where europe's gonna be
the state of jihad and of Islamism and
all that are you hopeful it doesn't feel
very hopeful right now the only grain
that i can get that's hopeful is that
these conversations are happening and at
least that the free thinkers aren't
feeling as held hostage between
jihadists and leftists so I think that's
the hope for me but I don't know how big
how really hopeful I can hang my hat on
that well I I am by nature an optimist I
couldn't do the job if I were not an
optimist and I do think there is reason
for hope because if I look at the emails
that I received a tweet that I received
the private messages that I receive the
feedback that I received when I talk to
people people are waking up in our own
countries I mean I have many people come
to me and say like you're actually
saying what I would like to say but
either they're you know they're too
afraid to say it because they'll be
called erases or they don't have the
rhetoric to really bring across their
views which is why shows like yours are
so important but also people in the
Muslim world I mean the Muslim women
that we work with who really no longer
want to live under oppression who don't
want to be treated as second-class
citizens who have the right to education
and to opportunity in life the free
thinkers that the poets that the
journalists the activists minorities
like homosexual converts atheists these
are the most important people in the
Muslim world at the moment and who
deserve all the respect and support that
we can give them
I think if we can forge a genuine
alliance between those in the Muslim
world who want to see change and want to
make Islam compatible with a modern
world and us who are not afraid to speak
out about the problems of the religion
and about the ideology because you know
the irony is that by denying all of this
you are actually aiding the extremists
because you're taking away you're taking
away the justification for those who
want to bring about change why they want
to bring about change
if you don't name the problem if you
take away the problem what are these
people going to do so that's me to
realize yeah at the top of the show I
said you know as you've said that a
religion is just a set of ideas and if
there was a political ideology a
political party let's say that it was an
offshoot of the Republicans here in the
United States and it said we're gonna
throw gays off roofs and we're gonna put
women in burkas and we're gonna oppress
minorities well then the progressives
would be going bonkers and they'd be
they'd be calling them the racists
instead well I think you know where I'm
going with this well Julia it was really
a pleasure talking to you
and well that's it was my pleasure thank
you so much for having me on the show
yeah thank you and you guys can find out
more about Julie and the work she does
follow her on Twitter it's MS julilah
nars and check out her work at HS center
org it's Center spelled the the British
Way